- [Dan] What are you doin' with that?
- Mentos and Coke, have
you see this before?
- No.
- What you do, right?
You get some Coke, you get some Mentos.
That's pretty cool.
- Good.
Ready?
- [Gavin] Yeah.
That looked good.
I liked your gnarly flip
through that stream of coke.
- Yeah?
- [Gavin] I wanna give that a go.
I think we should do one at the same time.
- Both of us?
- [Gavin] But, who the hell's gonna put
the Mentos in the bottle?
Oh, all right.
- Hello.
- [Gavin] This is Georgia.
What is your channel called?
- GB Film Productions.
- [Gavin] GB Film Productions, okay,
everyone should check that out.
There's some short films, they're cool.
And have you ever put Mentos
in a coke bottle before?
- Never, I've never done that before.
- [Gavin] What's your approach gonna be?
Like what are you gonna?
You gotta get as many in as possible.
- Yeah, I'm just gonna try
and flood it all in there
and see how high it can go.
- There's a lotta technique
to this, you know?
So yeah, I've been doin'
it for a few years now so.
- [Georgia] Practicing, yeah.
- This is gonna be mega-wide.
- [Georgia] Yeah, just
wanna have it on you.
- Right, so have the funnel ready.
Is the funnel good, yeah?
- Yep.
- Ready?
- [Gavin] Yep.
Do it.
Right-O.
Stop it, yeah.
- [Georgia] Oh my god.
- So we finally filmed Mentos and Coke
like everyone's been asking
for for about a year.
Thought it went rather well.
Good altitude on the coke.
- Yeah.
- Tryin' a Mento?
- I've never had a Mento.
- No?
- I've never tried one either.
- I'm gonna try one like this.
- Mine's all hard.
- Mine's kind of wet and sticky.
- Are you tryin' to get
one from the bottom?
- It went down my throat like.
- I think puttin' them in Diet Coke
is actually what they were designed for.
- Yeah, I think that's.
- That's their only good use.
- It's the most of efficient use of that.
- These definitely weren't.
They weren't designed for
consumption, I don't think.
- No.
- See ya in the next one.